-You moved for this show.
-Yeah.
-And so it's been five years.
Now you fully live in the U.K.
-Yeah. I mean, I thought -- we
literally, like, put our stuff
in storage and I told my wife,
"We'll probably be there
six months.
They're gonna cancel it
immediately."
And then they didn't and now we
have been there --
we've had children there.
I mean, we're totally
plugged in. Yeah.
-And that's it.
Do you miss it when you come
back for something like this?
Do you see things that you miss?
-Uh, no.
[ Laughter ]
No, of course, I do. Absolutely.
I mean, sandwiches here are
larger, which is important.
I miss the nature.
Like, there's wonderful nature
in the U.K.
but it's more rolling hills.
It's a gentler nature.
We lived in California where you
can get eaten by an earthquake
and killed by a tidal wave.
And I, like -- nature should be
able to kill you like that.
That's what I'm used to.
[ Laughter ]
And so it's
a little softer there,
which sometimes I have
difficulty with.
-You've never been to
Hampstead Heath, then.
All happening there.
In the bushes.
-You grew up in Ireland.
-Yes.
-On a turkey farm or adjacent to
a turkey farm?
-No, it was -- it wasn't on top
of the turkey farm.
-You were plucking.
You were plucking.
-Did you pluck?
-Yes, yeah, I plucked.
-Wow.
-That's how I got my money
for records and sweets.
-Gotcha.
And was it during the plucking
that you thought,
"I'm gonna be a writer"?
-It's such a natural route
from poultry farming
into comedy writing.
No, I mean, I think
it gave me --
Yeah, it definitely affected
my personality that I have.
All my brothers and sisters
and I have PTSD from that.
-She'll just stare off
into the distance
when we're writing sometimes and
I'm like, "Is it the turkeys?"
[ Laughter ]
-But it's like,
you know, Christmas --
if you farm turkeys
for a living,
my dad -- there was five kids.
It was the only time
he made money.
Like, we have no Disneyland
in Ireland, so there was no --
I mean, we would have been
selling legs
left, right and center.
[ Laughter ]
-You just had to wait.
-Just Christmas. Yeah.
-And were there other --
I mean, obviously you guys
are both in marriages.
You both have kids.
So obviously that inspired
a lot in the show.
And then were there other things
that would happen
that would find their way
into the show?
Like, did you --
Once you start going into
season two, three, and four
of something like this,
are you just -- your antenna
constantly up, hoping for things
to happen to you that you can
put in the show?
-Yeah, I mean, one time I came
in to write in the morning,
and I said, "Guess what happened
to me last night.
I was jogging, and a guy came up
to me on a bike
under cover of night
and squirted liquid in my face."
And I was like, "Oh, my God!"
Like, I literally --
"It's acid!"
And I was like, "I'm probably
starting to go blind."
I was like,
"No, wait, oh, it's juice."
[ Laughter ]
And so I told Sharon that.
I was, like,
"I was really scared."
And she just was laughing.
And she was like --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. That's episode three.
-Do you -- I mean, obviously,
132 countries watch this show.
So, obviously, it's a universal
topic that you're writing about,
but when you do press, like,
is it different to talk about
the show in the U.K.
than when you come here
and talk about it in the U.S.?
Do people ask you
different questions
about it depending
where you are?
-Well, they -- I think
the U.S. and the U.K.
kind of view it
slightly differently.
Like, an American audience seems
to get a little bit more upset
with us when
we're mean to each other.
Or if we end on a bad note,
like the end of season one was.
We had this horrible fight.
-Yeah.
-You called me an ingrate shrew.
-I called you, you know,
an American prick.
I can't remember.
And then my water's broke,
and then we just ended the show.
[ Laughter ]
And, yeah.
-British people are like,
"Yes, of course.
Naturally, yes, it's terrible.
Yes."
-Terrible things happen.
-Terrible things happened.
Whereas American people
are like,
"Wait, that's -- no, we have to
go back and do it again nice."
[ Laughter ]
But then after four seasons,
Americans are like,
"Oh, yeah, I know
what they're gonna do."
And they're more used to
our misanthropic --
-I feel like at this point
you certainly know
what you're signing up for
when you're watching an episode
of "Catastrophe."
I'm assuming, as you should be,
you're very proud of the show.
Are there scripts earlier
in your life?
Are there things you've written
that you were less proud of?
I feel like
that's very rewarding
for young writers to hear,
that you just don't start
at this place.
-Well, for the young writers,
yes. Many, many.
I mean, many failed pilots,
like Rob.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I've got them, too.
One time I thought,
"You know what?
I really like
'The Wizard of Oz.'
What if I rewrote it?"
And I readapted about half of
the book by L. Frank Baum
and then brought it to
a production company,
and they were like,
"You've got to be --
it's the most beloved -- they
did it better than you could.
Go. Get out of here."
So my subpar adaptation of
"The Wizard of Oz"
likely won't be seen.
-Never got produced.
-Believe it or not.
-One of the first scripts
I ever wrote
was about the Irish famine.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
-So, me and my writing partner
at the time thought
a period of mass starvation
in Ireland in 1845
would be ripe for laughs.
-You wrote it as a comedy?
-Wrote it as a comedy.
-Oh, wow.
-We called it "The Good Blight."
[ Laughter ]
After "The Good Life."
And I think it was, like,
a small --
it was an Irish family
on a small holding.
And a fun sort of
British landlord.
And I'm so glad I can't remember
any of the plots
because I would, you know,
take myself out.
-Well, sometimes those failures,
you learn lessons.
-You need to build --
The palace of success
can only be reached
with a pile of failures.
-Yes.
Well, this success is really
one that means so much to me
and to so many other people.
Thank you guys so much for being
here and congrats on the show.